qui est qui qu'est ce qui vous manque le
plus de tp mp moi c'est mathieu et
isabelle mathieu isabelle danois alors
celui qui vous manque le moins ces pages
il paraît que vous êtes énervé après
capucine jour capuche et j'ai pas lu
votre livre et je le dirai pas
laissez-moi baisse va diffuser un truc
mal la patrie comme d'ailleurs carole de
lettres qui m'a beaucoup et il répond
écrite à l'eau il avait raconté elle
c'est un journal intime que j'ai écris
depuis tout petit je vais donner parfois
quand elle écrivait trop bien je disais
non ça me ressemble pas fait écrire un
peu moins torgau faisait ça mange les
mines elle écrit alors capucines oui là
chez moi là chez nous c'est bon vous
avez été ici vous avez bossé avec la
tête vous dans le livre un an
mais je parle de votre promo quand vous
taclez méchant mais qui nous demandait
on est calé au moins la décence d'avoir
la reconnaissance du ventre à bosser ici
tétouan vous êtes mon époux et non mais
pourquoi elle nous tacle mais ce que je
ressens vous étiez le premier à me
tacler an dernier où il était une crue
sera du talent on connaît maintenant
elle tacle et plus pourquoi vous j'en ai
marre des gens qui font leur promo sur
le dos des chroniqueurs et de l'émission
et j'en ai ras-le-bol
je pense que vous franchement vous
emporter pour rien c'est juste un mec
qui lui demande de donner un avis sur
chaque chroniqueur et de dire qu'elle
est pour lequel ce qu'elle ressent sur
lui dans l'émission est ce qu'elle est à
peu près son rôle dans l'émission on
sent que le matériau est monté je pense
que se développer et pc je peux me
permettre
y'a que la vérité qui fâche voilà où là
[Applaudissements]